George Gordon studied economics at
Cornell University
after spending 1943 through 1945 with
the United States Marine Corps in the
Pacific leaving College in 1952 mr.
Gordon
immediately began work for Standard Oil
and I was a land man still him whatever
I can do in Michigan Illinois Kentucky
and so forth and I eventually ended up
here when he bought Rockwell Lake and
the surrounding property in 1995 local
area fishermen called the property by
another name perch Lake supposedly an
average of 30 feet deep the lake had a
long history as an anglers paradise home
to several species of fish including
largemouth bass bluegill perch and trout
mr. Gordon remembers checking with some
of the neighbors before purchasing the
property they knew the lake is a fishing
lake full of trout many of the area
neighbors hadn't been there in years but
most remembered fishing in percs Lake I
went up there with a friend of mine went
up there
and we went to fishing on rockwell lake
and when it was I think was average
three foot deep about that time a
subsequent survey of the lake however
revealed that over the years sedimentary
deposits in a lake had reduced it to no
more than nine feet at its deepest point
at the lakes dissolved oxygen level and
high volume of mud
it was poisoning its outlet Fairbanks
Creek Gordon and his surveyors also
found that due to the reduced depth most
fish would be susceptible to a winter
freeze they concluded that if the lake
was to sustain a large fish population
it would have to be dredged in 1998 the
dredging project began according to mr.
Gordon the difficulty with this endeavor
became apparent immediately the mud and
Rockwell Lake would not settle used a
mud I think settles [ __ ] it let does not
settle to light its powdery and so they
have a problem with it always moving in
and out and so forth and up and down it
and it won't settle on the ground stay
there eventually
the lake would need to be dredged twice
in order to separate the mud from the
water
mr. Gordon gave the property to
Hillsdale College as a bio station in
1999 since then the students and faculty
of hills dales biology department have
been using the lake and Fairbanks Creek
to conduct scientific research students
projects up here run the gamut from
fisheries management in our lake to
genetic population genetic studies of
insects fish small mammals we've done
radio telemetry we've looked at
organisms and their ability to monitor
against pollution both chemical and
thermal we've done insect chemical
communication so sky's the limit
it's a beautiful lake especially at
night you know it is it's a
beautiful thing and people are getting
to use it more and more which is good
the most important thing to me is to see
we have crowds up there and and to talk
to people and you know they like it and
they come back